the chief of police in aurora colorado
is apologizing
after a brutal arrest captured on the
body cameras of two officers
the footage was released yesterday and
we want to warn you it is
disturbing kyle vinson was arrested
friday on an
outstanding warrant charge within
minutes he was left
beaten and bloodied saying he was
fighting for his life
jeff begues is following this latest
controversy for the aurora police
department
the body camera videos show officers
attempting to arrest three men with
outstanding felony warrants
when two flee the scene kyle vinson is
left sitting alone
officer john haubert is seen pointing a
gun at vincent
ordering him to lie face down and show
his hands
which he does hands all the way out
hands all the way out front
the officer hits vinson with his pistol
at least seven
times one cut on vincent's head required
six stitches
he later holds him by the neck for
almost 40 seconds
vincent's father says he was shocked by
what he saw
i thought he was gonna die because he
said you're killing me
on your face get on your face dude
aurora's police chief vanessa wilson
calls the arrest a despicable
we're disgusted we're angry
this is not police work this is not the
aurora police department
this was criminal since becoming chief
in 2020 wilson has worked to reform the
aurora police department
terminating 14 officers for misconduct
the year before she became chief 23 year
old elijah mclean
died after aurora police put him in a
neck hold
and paramedics injected him with
ketamine after he was stopped while
walking home from a convenience store
wilson says as soon as she saw this new
video she ordered an internal affairs
investigation
you move i will shoot you me wilson says
she supports the quick
release of body camera videos which is
now required by colorado law within 21
days in incidents where there
are complaints and that's why i'm doing
it here today
because you have a right to know what
happened officer haubert faces
multiple felony charges including
second-degree assault
and attempted first-degree assault
another officer on the scene francine
martinez faces misdemeanor charges for
failing to intervene
or report the use of force
authorities have yet to say whether
vinson will face charges for an
outstanding warrant on a probation
violation
i didn't do anything dude
i was just fighting for my life man
officer hobart is on administrative
leave without pay his lawyer would not
comment but says that he will
zealously defend his client officer
martinez is on leave with pay which is
department policy when charged with a
non-felony
we are seeking comment from her or her
attorney
but so far jericho we have not heard
back
wow jeff that video is hard to watch but
once again video
holding officers accountable thank you